et François nelbuffet nous accompagne
durant cette devenir sénateur et l'air
du Rhône où va donc passer le Tour de
France absolument ce qui va vous réjouir
avec grand plaisir et président de la
commission des lois vous avez remis un
rapport sur l'avenir institutionnel de
la Nouvelle-Calédonie on va en parler
mais d'abord l'actualité on l'a vu c'est
donc ce dispositif de sécurité annoncé
par géralda Manin pour les festivités du
14 juillet 45000 policiers et gendarmes
chaque soir pendant plusieurs soirs pour
faire face aux risques d'incident est-ce
que c'est le signe que des émeutes sont
à craindre il a notamment cité
l'Île-de-France le nord la région
lyonnaise particulièrement se
surveillance
à des informations de la part des
services de renseignement naturellement
et qu'ils sentent qu'il est possible
qu'il y ait des mouvements de violence
il faut donc le prévoir et l'anticiper
ils ont raison de le faire il y a aucun
doute là-dessus ce qui est parfaitement
regrettable c'est le fait que pour une
manifestation festive la fête nationale
de grands événements soit obligé d'en
arriver là et que la question c'est
moins de savoir quel dispositif il faut
mettre en place certains pour ne pas
reculer devant ceux qui veulent semer la
violence naturellement
et de savoir effectivement comment
traiter cette violence-là donc c'est
aller au fond des choses tirer les
consignes les conséquences de ses
émeutes et de prendre les bonnes mesures
c'est de ne rien mettre sur le tapis
c'est la ne rien mettre sous le tapis
regarder tout ce qui n'a pas fonctionné
ça va être la mission que va faire la
commission des lois dès la rentrée nous
l'avons décidé hier en commission
d'analyser les raisons de ces événements
le comportement des forces de l'ordre le
profil des émeutiers les raisons de leur
action leur composition de façon à
parfaitement identifier les choses est
en capacité d'apporter des réponses
vous demandez même les pouvoirs d'une
commission alors effectivement nous
demanderons à la rentrée les pouvoirs
d'une commission d'enquête mais nous
avons d'ores et déjà décidé la mise en
place cette mission hier quel objectif
qu'est-ce que vous en attendez précisé
c'est vraiment d'aller au bout de la
compréhension de ce qui s'est passé et
de savoir qui a fait quoi et de savoir
pourquoi on en est arrivé là car a pu
voir sur les déclarations qui ont été
faites ces dernières semaines il y a
plusieurs facteurs bien sûr que le sujet
des banlieues il y a des communes où il
n'y a pas de de problèmes de banlieue il
y a eu des violences où il y a eu des
jeunes 30% de jeunes sont allés dans la
rue détruire des bâtiments publics les
symboles de la République qui l'école la
mairie le tribunal voir certaines
prisons il y a quelque chose qui se
passe donc on a raté quelque chose
probablement collectivement mais la
reprise en main elle est nécessaire
alors si on veut donc prise en main qui
soit efficace encore faut-il tout dire
et tout mettre sur la table et ne rien
cacher parce que il y a que la vérité
c'est l'ultra gauche c'est l'ultra
droite on n'a jamais raté l'intégration
on a raté l'intégration enfin stop aux
déclarations de toute nature regardons
la vérité en face ce qui s'est
réellement passé et apportant les bonnes
réponses je crois qu'on doit ça aux
Français et puis on doit ça tout
simplement à la tranquillité publique et
la vie en société est-ce que dans votre
mission d'information peut-être
commission d'enquête vous vous entendrez
des anciens ministres un président de la
République on peut entendre tout le
monde et on va entendre tout le monde
moi je veux savoir précisément ce qui
s'est passé je veux savoir les raisons
de tout cela et les raisons de la
réussite de certains points et la raison
de l'échec la carte si on essaye de
regarder la carte de ces événements elle
est très intéressante à regarder des
territoires très différents ont eu des
mouvements de violence et certains qui
auraient dû en avoir n'en n'ont pas eu
tiens pourquoi
donc il n'y a pas de ça ça vous
interroge vous avez un début de réponse
on sait que dans certains quartiers le
trafic de stupéfiants il y a le marché
on casse pas le marché et donc voilà
donc on ne sait pas les mute mais
qu'ailleurs ça pose pas de problème mais
pourquoi un jeune je rappelle que le
plus jeune dans les émeutes à 11 ans 11
ans qu'est-ce qui fait qu'un gamin de 11
ans le soir dans la rue va casser son
école sa bibliothèque ou incendie la
voiture de du père son copain ça a pas
de sens est-ce que ça commence aussi au
quinquennat de Nicolas Sarkozy et les
effectifs de policiers et de gendarmes
ont diminué elle parle aussi de ça
bien sûr qu'on va regarder ça mais il y
a plusieurs facteurs il y a sans doute
le fait que moins de présence policière
au sein des au sein des territoires à
compter mais on a un problème
d'éducation
on a un problème de respect on a un
problème de que les jeunes comprennent
que ben voilà on a un bien commun on le
partage on vit en société et tous ces
sujets là ils sont ils sont fondamentaux
mais regardez la ville de Lyon par
exemple sur ces événements quand on dit
la police n'était pas sur place mais on
croit savoir que la police municipale de
Lyon n'est pas intervenu dans une
imaginable et en même temps on se dit
mais pourquoi des fois
du maire qui n'a pas souhaité engager sa
police municipale mais on est aussi
service de la population et on est
complémentaires de la police nationale
on fait pas le même travail mais on est
complémentaire donc dans ces situations
là on joue collectif
dans une situation
générale moi quand j'étais mère ma
police municipale elle était elle était
sur place c'était sur le terrain elle
était mobilisée elle faisait ce qu'elle
avait à faire mais elle était en
complément de ce que faisait la police
nationale c'est ça
je pense que oui je pense que les
policiers doit être renforcés je viens
de voir ce matin que sur la commune de
Vénissieux les policiers municipaux
étaient en grève parce qu'il demandait à
être armé et que la mère refuse
moi j'ai une police municipale
m'entraînante qui n'était pas armée et
un jour ils sont venus me voir en disant
il faut nous en met pas ce qu'on a un
risque pour nous je l'ai fait dans les
conditions bien particulières mais je
l'ai fait il faut penser que c'est un
système qui doit se mettre en place mais
au-delà de ça
lEducation la responsabilité des parents
on parle beaucoup en ce moment de de la
suspension des allocations familiales
des choses comme ça il faut faire moi je
suis partisan non pas d'une suppression
mais d'un système de suspension avec une
forme de mise sous tutelle on l'appelle
comme on veut pour sensibiliser les
parents ne pas punir les enfants
naturellement parce qu'il y a c'est pour
eux que c'est fait on est bien d'accord
mais il y a un moment il faut rappeler
la règle
vous savez c'est une question de fond
d'éducation si on ne fait pas ça on y
arrivera jamais Emmanuel Macron choisit
de ne pas prendre la parole demain à
l'occasion du 14 juillet vous le
regrettez
on a c'est assez étonnant parce qu'une
fois on prend la parole une fois on
prend pas la parole moi je trouve que la
parole présidentielle au moment de la
fête nationale elle est utile elle est
nécessaire donc de ce point de vue là je
regarde à condition d'avoir quelque
chose à dire naturellement si c'est une
réunion qu'on a pour un propos qui ne
dit rien de nouveau et c'est pas très
intéressant mais sur les choses qui se
préparent mais je trouve que il y a des
moments forts dans la République il y a
des moments qui sont incarnés et la fête
nationale c'est l'occasion aussi pour le
président de la République de s'adresser
à la nation j'aurais préféré sur le
principe en tous les cas que ça se passe
comme ça on arrive au terme des 100
jours et parmi les textes qui étaient
engagés il y a la loi immigration qui
finalement ne sera pas présentée au mois
de juillet comme ça avait été évoqué
est-ce que ça veut dire que les
discussions avec les républicains ont
échoué non ça veut dire qu'elle se
continue bon chacun sait ici que le
texte sur l'immigration j'emporte une
grande partie
il faut avancer il faut discuter elles
ont besoin de reprendre la main avec le
gouvernement la discussion va s'ouvre
est ouverte en réalité le Sénat a voté
et la commission des lois voté un texte
qui est existant qui est une base de
travail intéressante la majorité
sénatoriale a des positions il faut
penser à ça le texte bien sûr est-ce que
Céline rouge vous êtes prêt à aller
revoir pour trouver un compromis avec le
gouvernement notamment sur la question
des métiers en tension il y en a une sur
laquelle nous sommes très ferme c'est la
question des métiers en tension elle a
régularisation de personnes en situation
irrégulière même si les critères sont
assouplis parce pas obligé du socle nous
disait qu'il était prêt à assouplir les
chrétiens je pense que je pense
qu'au-delà de tout on n'a pas besoin
d'un texte législatif pour ça il existe
un dispositif qui s'appelle l'admission
exceptionnelle au séjour dans le pouvoir
est confié au préfet qui se traite par
voie de circulaire et Monsieur dupe peut
parfaitement à son initiative prendre
une circulaire que les préfets
appliqueront on peut discuter ensemble
des critères il y a pas de difficulté
là-dessus mais nous n'avons pas besoin
de texte législatif et je crois que si
on fonctionne comme ça on a réglé 80% du
problème puisque le reste du texte à mon
avis on devrait aboutir nous en avons
besoin
cette nuit à l'Assemblée nationale les
députés ont donné leur feu vert à une
composition d'érections 3000 places de
prison supplémentaires d'ici à 2027
c'est dans le texte justice parce que
j'imagine que vous sentez ça veut dire
qu'un accord va être possible sur ce
texte oui j'espère bien justice je pense
qu'on va aboutir à un accord et c'est
absolument nécessaire on va pas redire
tout ce qui se passe dans ce texte là
mais sur le les lieux privatifs de
liberté ça fait très longtemps que je
peine sur la diversification de ceci il
faut bien sûr des maisons pour les
crimes ça pose pas de problème pour les
délinquants il y a des moments où il
faut la surpopulation carcérale n'est
pas acceptable donc il faut de la place
il ne faut pas renoncer à
l'incarcération il faut des lieux de
semi liberté il faut des lieux plus
adaptés encore pour les mineurs dans la
problématique qui se posent à nous quel
est l'objectif c'est l'efficacité de la
peine la peine doit être exécutée
rapidement pour qu'elle ait un sens et
si on doit priver quelqu'un de sa
liberté il faut que en fonction de ce
qu'il est et y compris de l'infraction
commise on est des lieux qui soient
adaptés connaissez pas utile d'aller
mettre en détention provisoires dans un
grand centre pénitentiaire un gamin ou
un une personne qui a un prix
modélinquant sur les gouvernement c'est
parfois sur les collectivités qui ne
jouent pas le jeu alors ça c'est une
autre affaire
c'est vrai que les collectivités
rechignent à avoir un équipement
pénitentiaire
il faut travailler là-dessus je sais que
c'est difficile
j'ai les vécu sur mon territoire comme
beaucoup d'autres
mais il faut quand même avancer donc
après peut-être faut-il qu'à un moment
ou un autre le gouvernement elle est
moyen entre guillemets d'imposer quelque
chose parce que c'est l'intérêt national
qui doit l'emporter et puis aussi des
dogmes qu'il faut savoir donc il faut
savoir sortir le lieu d'implantation
faut être au Président
on peut aussi imaginer que ce soit un
peu à l'extérieur d'un centre-ville
enfin tout de même c'est pas dramatique
il y a un intérêt supérieur pour la
nation donc à un moment il faut il faut
avancer je crois qu'il faut être très
clair là-dessus
vous avez remis hier votre rapport après
trois référendum indépendance quel
avenir institutionnel pour l'archipel
c'est la question sur laquelle vous avez
travaillé on va voir les points de ce
rapport avec Audrey
[Musique]
bonjour Audrey bonjour et Audrey
françois-noëlle buffet a donc remis hier
son rapport sur l'avenir institutionnel
de la Nouvelle-Calédonie on va en parler
mais d'abord on va peut-être reposer les
bases avec vous pour qu'on comprenne
bien de quoi on parle oui la
Nouvelle-Calédonie c'est un archipel
français situé à l'est de l'Australie
ancienne colonie c'est maintenant une
collectivité d'outre-mer à statut
particulier je vous explique pourquoi
dans les années 80 la Nouvelle-Calédonie
connaît de violents affrontements entre
les indépendantistes et les loyalistes
ceux qui soutiennent le maintien de
l'archipel dans la République ça se
termine par un drame celui d'Ouvéa et la
mort de 19 Kanaks et deux gendarmes
alors on signe les accords de Matignon
ou Dino en 88 accord mise à jour avec
les accords de nouvelles N en 1998 en
résumé on met en place des institutions
censées être temporaires on transfère
des compétences de l'État aux
collectivité et surtout l'objectif c'est
que la population soit consultée par
référendum sur l'avenir de la
Nouvelle-Calédonie ces choses faites à
trois reprises entre 2018 et 2021 à
chaque fois le nom à l'indépendance
l'emporte vous le voyez on vous a donné
les chiffres mais il faut souligner que
pour le troisième scrutin où on a un nom
à 96,50% des voix il y a eu un appel au
boycot des indépendantistes et en fait
les suffrages exprimés ne sont que de
40% voilà pourquoi le chiffre est si
élevé et depuis ces trois référendum et
bien rien les discussions étaient
bloquées depuis deux ans alors que le
référendum devait ouvrir une nouvelle
page pour la Nouvelle-Calédonie pour
qu'elle puisse déterminer sa place dans
la République je vous proposais
d'écouter un son avant d'en venir une
interview avant d'en venir à votre
rapport c'est l'interview d'Élisabeth
borne la première ministre après une
tentative de reprise des négociations
les échanges ont été incomplets en
raison de l'absence d'une partie des
forces politiques
le processus que nous avons engagé
aujourd'hui ne peut aboutir que si
toutes les forces politiques
calédoniennes y contribuent
et François Noël buffet dans votre
rapport vous faites donc des
propositions quelles sont-elles Audrey
alors vous appelez à une reprise de
dialogue équilibrée où l'État joue le
rôle d'arbitre car il y a pu avoir des
incompréhensions qui ont bloqué les
discussions avec des absences notamment
l'idée d'un référendum de projet dont ce
sont sentis exclus les indépendantistes
et cette idée a été abandonnée vous le
soulignez dans le rapport vous soulignez
aussi l'absence de Sonia bacquesse la
secrétaire d'État auprès du ministre de
l'intérieur des décisions
gouvernementales c'est important parce
qu'elle fait partie des loyalistes et ça
aurait pu être perçu comme un signe mais
l'élément primordial ça concerne les
inscriptions sur les listes électorales
depuis les accords de Nouméa le droit de
vote est réservé aux personnes inscrites
avant
1998 cela devait permettre une meilleure
représentation de la population canacte
plus en plus minoritaire notamment au
moment des référendum sauf que 1998
c'était il y a 25 ans ça exclut toute
une partie de la population or l'année
prochaine il y a des élections
provinciales vous appelez donc dans
votre vos rapports à revoir les règles
avant cette échéance il en est de la
démocratie tout simplement et puis j'ai
une question un autre point de votre
rapport vous soulignez les fragilités du
système institutionnel que vous avez
relevé au moment des auditions quelles
sont-elles ces fragilités
[Rires]
c'est un sujet très important qui vu de
métropole paraît lointain et pourtant il
est essentiel pour les habitants de
Nouvelle-Calédonie et il est essentiel
pour la France les trois référendum ont
lieu à la suite des accords de Matignon
et de Nouméa et donc
la Nouvelle-Calédonie a fait le choix de
rester dans la République je crois
qu'aujourd'hui c'est partager par tout
le monde la question est quel niveau
d'autonomie au sein de la République et
quelle organisation et quelle nouvelle
organisation tout le monde est prêt à
parler et je dois dire que le travail
qu'a fait le Sénat l'année dernière avec
une mission nous sommes allés avec
Philippe Bas et Jean-Pierre Sueur
pendant une grosse semaine on a
auditionné beaucoup de monde on a permis
de renouer le dialogue jeudi on a permis
parce que je crois sincèrement et
finalement de remettre en jeu la
discussion qui doit s'installer entre la
nouvelle Kennedy enfin c'est
représentants et le gouvernement
première chose deuxième chose oui il y a
plusieurs sujets vous les avez évoqué le
corps électoral est un sujet majeur je
rappelle qu'il y a trois corps il y a
trois dispositifs en Nouvelle-Calédonie
mais pour les élections provinciales qui
ont lieu en principe en 2024 il faut
évoluer c'est un sujet de débat et de
discussion j'imagine que
la discussion a redémarré et on devrait
aboutir à un accord mais il y a aussi
d'autres aspects d'organisation des
institutions locales
notamment du rôle des provinces
notamment du rôle des communes que l'on
veut renforcer puisque c'est elle qui
finalement au quotidien font vivre tout
le monde et ils y arrivent et ils
fonctionnent très très bien et puis
c'est la perspective qu'il faut donner à
ce territoire la Nouvelle-Calédonie
c'est des usines de nickel c'est une
vraie richesse un lieu merveilleux et
c'est une communauté une vie hors ce
territoire perd des habitants maintenant
depuis plusieurs années et sont issus
économiques est en train de se déliter
il faut donc redonner de la perspective
et ce que l'on a dit c'est que même si
l'autodétermination qui reste un
principe qu'on constitutionnel pardon
article 53 de la Constitution n'est pas
à remettre en cause mais personne ne le
remet en cause il est nécessaire qu'il
se mette d'accord pour un projet qui
s'inscrivent dans la durée pour donner
de la de la visibilité à la fois
aux dirigeants Calédonie mais aussi au
moment d'économique qui reviennent sur
place à la population qui reprend
confiance et à ce salut commun que de
dire ça mais à ce destin commun qu'ils
doivent avoir ensemble et c'est de la
confiance d'abord entre les uns et les
autres c'est aussi comme il les disent
du respect de l'humilité c'est ce que
dit la coutume entre eux et on doit
pouvoir avancer pour que ça marche il
faut que l'accord il soit local et qu'il
soit d'accord entre eux et ensuite le
gouvernement j'allais dire donnera son
accord facilitera les choses et nous
parlementaires on fera le travail pour
que la Nouvelle-Calédonie retrouve cette
perspective vraiment
c'est loin de la métropole mais c'est la
France ce sont nos concitoyens et dans
un domaine où la situation dans
l'adopacifique est importante c'est
aussi l'intérêt de pays c'est aussi
l'intérêt de la France mais c'est aussi
l'intérêt de nos concitoyens qu'il
trouve ce cette capacité à vivre
ensemble qu'ils font d'ailleurs au
quotidien et les jeunes générations
elles ont envie aussi après ces
événements dramatiques avec une
Nouvelle-Calédonie de tourner la page et
de vivre les choses importantes il y a
des actions qui ont été menées sur le
timer qui sont passionnantes on n'a pas
le temps de parler de tout le rapport
mais j'espère que le voyage du président
de la République va permettre justement
voyage du chef de l'État fin juillet et
dans votre rapport vous appelez un geste
de décolonisation de la part du chef de
l'État qu'est-ce que ça veut dire et
qu'est-ce que pourrait être ça on parle
singulièrement de décolonisation
culturelle c'est-à-dire d'une évolution
des esprits
je le disais l'autodétermination est
constitutionnel il le décideront quand
il le voudront un moment ou un autre
mais la décolonisation des esprits c'est
le fait que
indépendantiste et loyalistes
et bien ce respectent dans ce qu'ils
sont mais ils le font déjà en réalité
mais le dis-je publiquement et que
publiquement les choses soient faites il
y a du il y a déjà eu des signes forts
la poignée de main et cette statue sur
la place de Nouméa les deux drapeaux qui
ont été hissés sur la place de Nouméa
Alicia qui d'ailleurs de notre collègue
Pierre Frugier il faut le rappeler voilà
c'est ça la décolonisation culturelle le
président de la République a remis
l'acte de possession que la France avait
la Nouvelle-Calédonie il y a quelques
années à Nouméa mais peut-être qu'il
faut le faire un autre geste pour
montrer que chacun se respecte et qu'ils
ont un avenir commun et que c'était eux
le construire
se déplace en Nouvelle-Calédonie
peut-être fera-t-il des propositions
mais on pense que c'est utile à ce que
les les choses continuent d'évoluer
positivement le dialogue a redémarré
depuis un an on doit maintenant être
dans le concret si on veut que ces
élections édules en 2024 merci
directeur de la publication de Lyon Mag
bonjour Alexis merci d'être là on va
parler d'un dossier qui inquiète dans la
région lyonnaise c'est la présence d'une
pollution au Père fluorée oui c'est un
sujet qui a pas encore de portée
nationale mais qui selon moi mérite une
mise en lumière vous l'avez dit les
habitants du sud-ouest de
l'agglomération lyonnaise on leur lot
d'inquiétude récente que ça soit à cause
d'un projet téléphérique ou d'une fusion
de commune mais puis un an et demi
beaucoup s'interrogent sur l'ampleur de
la pollution au perfluoré alors ici la
préfecture multiplie les analyses avec
la DDPP et les résultats sont sans appel
les œufs de poulailler de particulier de
12 communes sont contaminées par ces
polluants éternels ce qui veut dire que
les seules le sont également
probablement à cause des industries
voisines à François Noël buffet vous
avez été le maire d'Oullins qui est
l'une des villes qui est directement
concernée par ses perles la population
attend évidemment des réponses au plus
vite des réponses sanitaires mais aussi
légales et justement la loi
d'encadrement des péfastes comme on ce
qu'on appelle aussi a été repoussé deux
ans ce qu'on prend pas trop le temps
avant d'agir concrètement selon vous
c'est un sujet important qui concerne la
partie sud de la métropole le lion et
les communes les dernières mesures qui
ont été faites sur
inquiétantes quand même puisqu'on est au
delà des tolérances qui sont faites par
les par les spécialistes il y a des
interdictions d'ailleurs qui ont été
prises par la préfecture il faut qu'elle
soit confortée et il faut être très très
ferme là-dessus le principe de
précaution est essentiel on prend pas de
risques mais on parle des œufs pour des
œufs bien sûr mais on parle il y a des
sujets de pour la grossesse pour les
femmes qui sont enceintes pour les
enfants enfin il y a beaucoup de sujets
importants de santé publique donc là il
faut être très ferme on discute pas et
en revanche le texte il faut le faire
avancer le plus vite possible on ne peut
pas attendre c'est vrai que c'est un
sujet qui pour l'instant est resté
extrêmement local mais qui a une qui est
un sujet finalement national parce que
il est pas dit que ça n'existe pas
ailleurs les origines des pollutions de
cette nature sont essentiellement
industrielles d'ailleurs et elles sont
identifié il faut aussi que le monde
industriel fasse des efforts c'est les
rejets d'eau dans le fleuve dans la
circonstance les rejets plutôt de oui
nous dans le fleuve donc là il faut être
très très ferme et si on doit avancer le
texte il faut que le gouvernement le
prenne en main tout de suite on est
capable de se réunir la semaine
prochaine pour reconstruire les
bâtiments détruits à l'occasion des
émeutes on doit bien être capable quand
même de se retrouver rapidement pour
traiter les problèmes sur des publics
aussi important que cela en tous les cas
je crois sincèrement puisque on voulait
évoquer il y a un besoin d'informations
publiques encore plus important me
semble-t-il ça reste encore un sujet
confidentiel j'ai des localement même
s'il y a les mers sont au courant
agissent bien évidemment mais ça
mériterait une information me
semble-t-il encore plus large
[Musique]
français était lyonnais c'est à la Une
de Lyon Mag merci beaucoup Alexandrie
d'avoir été avec nous on va dire un mot
avant de se quitter pour sonner le
buffet de cette interview ce matin dans
Le Figaro de Laurent Wauquiez qui
appelle Emmanuel Macron une forme
d'union sacrée pas de quoi mais il
souhaite surmonter temporairement les
divisions et se mettre d'accord sur des
grands textes c'est ce qu'il faut faire
c'est ce que je pense
la situation est-elle politique
j'entends la fragmentation du pays
j'allais dire la communautarisation du
pays quel que soit la nature de la
communauté d'ailleurs est-elle que on ne
sait plus où est le destinational donc
il y a besoin de le reconstruire et sur
les sujets majeurs qui sont les sujets
migratoires les sujets de sécurité et
quelques autres grands sujets qu'on
évoque plus suffisamment l'enjeu
économique tout ce qui touche à la
souveraineté de la France on a réussi à
le faire programmation militaire
nécessite que l'on ait des accords entre
Jean responsable et républicain oui il
le faut alors il faut avoir un discours
clair là une fois de plus c'est comme
pour la mission sur les émeutes c'est un
discours de vérité parce que nous le
devons à nous-mêmes c'est une chose mais
nous le devons français à cette clarté
s'ils veulent retrouver confiance dans
le monde politique et dans le destin de
notre pays il faut a perdu du mot qu'on
est cet accord transparent clair et
précis tous les républicains sont prêts
à cet accord ecoutez je pense que tout
son responsables en tous les cas pour
ceux qui ont qui ont majoritairement la
conscience de l'intérêt général sont
bien sûr en capacité de d'être en accord
avec ça je le crois sincèrement un
Premier ministre issu de vos rang aussi
ça veut dire d'abord un discours de
transparence et de vérité ça c'est le
point de base ensuite faut-il un Premier
ministre qui dépendent de nous qui
souhaitent chez nous ou en tous les cas
proche
mettons nous d'abord d'accord sur ce que
l'on veut faire et sur le programme
ensuite la personnalité qui incarnera le
mieux et bien on verra mais ça peut être
dans le Figaro
et le Premier ministre se trouvait une
ça peut être lui bien sûr ça peut être
d'autres je veux pas fermer la porte
mais ça peut être lui mais surtout c'est
d'abord la discussion de fond il ne peut
pas y avoir d'accord d'alcove pour des
raisons X ou Y personnel le pas
personnel c'est d'abord sur des sujets
de fonds d'ailleurs les Français ne
comprendraient pas qui dit qu'il n'y ait
pas d'abord une discussion sur le fond
et ils auraient bien raison de ne pas le
comprendre et moi je soutiens le fait
qu'il faut une discussion sur le fond et
sur quel texte les sujets qu'on vient
d'évoquer qui sont les sujets essentiels
les migrations des huiles essentielles
mais c'est pas le seul non plus on vient
de l'avoir sur les forces armées on doit
la voir sur la sécurité mais on doit la
voir sur la souveraineté alimentaire on
doit l'avoir sur le développement
économique c'est tout ces sujets là sur
l'éducation si on a un sur lequel il
faut au-delà des autres sur lequel il
faut avancer c'est le sujet de
l'éducation ce que nous venons de vivre
ne peut pas continuer comme ça qu'est-ce
qui fait destin collectif qu'est-ce qui
fait qu'on ait envie d'avoir ensemble le
souhait de vivre ensemble et de
développer notre pays et d'avancer quoi
c'est ça moi je veux qu'on pose la
question à quelqu'un le matin en lui
disant c'est quoi d'être français c'est
quoi le destinational pour vous c'est
quoi le partage
merci beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité
pour cette dernière émission de la
saison de bonnes vacances à vous aussi
on vous retrouve évidemment on vous
retrouve à la rentrée merci d'avoir été
notre invité dans 20 minutes dans le
club des territoires on reparlera du
dispositif de sécurité annoncé par
Gérald Darmanin pour sécuriser les
festivités du 14 juillet on en parle
tout de suite avec notre invité c'est la
ministre Agnès Firmin le Bodo qui nous
rejoint